what about the risk of will AI lead to
crippling inequality
you know because we're kind of saying
everybody's life will become better
is it possible that the the rich get
richer here yeah so this actually
ironically goes back to Marxism so um
because this was the card so the court
claim of Marxism right basically it was
that the owner the owners of capital
would basically on the means of
production and then over time they would
basically accumulate all the wealth the
workers would be paying in you know and
getting nothing in return because they
wouldn't be needed anymore right Marx
was very worried about what he called
mechanization or what later became known
as automation
um and that you know the workers would
be miserated and the capitalists would
end up with with all and so this was one
of the core core core principles of
Marxism of course it turned out to be
wrong about every previous wave of
Technology
um the reason it turned out to be wrong
about every previous wave of technology
is that the way that the self-interested
owner of the machines makes the most
money is by providing the production
capability in the form of products and
services to the most people the most
customers as possible Right the largest
and this is one of those funny things
where every CEO knows this intuitively
and yet it's like hard to explain from
the outside the the way you make the
most money in any business is by selling
to the largest market you can possibly
get to the largest market you can
possibly get to is everybody the planet
and so every large company does is
everything that it can to drive down
prices to be able to get volumes up to
be able to get to everybody on the
planet and that happened with everything
from electricity it happened with
telephones it happened with radio it
happened with automobiles it happened
with smartphones it happened with the
PCS it happened with the internet it
happened with mobile broadband it's
happened by the way with Coca-Cola and
it's happened with like every you know
basically every industrially produced
you know good or service people you want
to drive it to the largest possible
market and then as proof of that it's
already happened right which is the
early adopters of like jgpt and Bing are
not like you know Exxon and Boeing
they're you know your uncle and your
nephew right it's just like free it's
either freely available online or it's
available for 20 bucks a month or
something but the it you know these
things went this this technology went
Mass Market immediately
um and so look the the owners of the
means of production whoever does this
doesn't mention the Australian dollar
questions there are people who are going
to get really rich doing this producing
these things but they're going to get
really rich by taking this technology to
the broadest possible Market
so yes they'll get rich but they'll get
rich having a huge positive impact on
yeah making that making the technology
available to everybody yeah right and
again smartphone same thing right so
there's this amazing kind of twist in um
in business history which is you cannot
spend ten thousand dollars on a
smartphone
right you can't spend a hundred thousand
dollars you can't spend like I would buy
the million dollar smartphone like I'm
signed up for it like if it's like
suppose a million dollar smartphone was
like much better than the thousand
dollar smartphone like I'm there to buy
it it doesn't exist why doesn't it exist
Apple makes so much more money driving
the price further down from a thousand
dollars than they would trying to
harvest right and so it's just this
repeating pattern you see over and over
again um where the and and what's what's
great about it what's great about it is
you do not need to rely on anybody's
enlightened right generosity to do this
you just need to rely on capitalist
self-interest
uh what about AI taking our jobs
yeah so very very similar thing here um
there's sort of a there's a core fallacy
which again was was very common in
Marxism which is What's called the lump
of Labor fallacy and this is sort of the
fallacy that there's a only a fixed
amount of work to be done in the world
and if the and it's all being done today
by people and then if machines do it
there's no other work to be done by
people
um and that's just a completely
backwards view on how the economy
develops and grows um because what
happens is not in fact that what happens
is the introduction of Technology into
production process causes prices to fall
as prices fall consumers have more
spending power is consumers have more
spending power they create new demand
that new demand then causes capital and
labor to form into new Enterprises to
satisfy nuance and needs and the result
is more jobs at higher wages the nuance
and needs the the worries that the the
creation of new wants and needs at a
rapid rate
well I mean there's a lot of turnover in
jobs so people will lose jobs just the
actual experience of losing a job and
having to learn new things and your
skills is painful for the individual
well two things one is that new jobs are
often much better
um so this actually came up that there
was this Panic about a decade ago and
all the truck drivers are going to lose
their jobs right and number one that
didn't happen because we haven't figured
out a way to actually finish that yet
but but the other thing was like
electric driver like I grew up in a town
that was basically consisted of a truck
stop right and I like knew a lot of
truck drivers and like truck drivers
live a decade shorter than everybody
else like they it's a it's a it's
actually like a very dangerous like they
get like literally they have like higher
rates of skin cancer and on the left
side of their on the left side of their
body from from being in the sun all the
time the vibration of being in the truck
is actually very damaging to your
physiology and there's actually uh
perhaps partially because of that reason
uh there's a shortage yeah of uh
people who want to be truck drivers yeah
like it's not it's not like the question
always you want to ask somebody like
that is do you want you know do you want
your kid to be doing this job and like
most of them will tell you no like I
want my kid to be sick in a cubicle
somewhere like where they don't have
this like where they don't die 10 years
earlier and so so the new jobs number
one the new jobs are often better but
you don't get the new jobs until you go
through the change and then to your
point the the training thing you know
it's always the issue is can can people
adapt and again here you need to imagine
living in a world in which everybody has
the AI assistant capability
right to be able to pick up new skills
much more quickly and be able to have
some you know be able to have a machine
to work with to augment their skills
it's still going to be painful but
that's the process of life it's painful
for some people I mean there's no look
there's no question it's painful for
some people and they're you know they're
yes it's not again I'm not a utopian on
this and it's not like it's positive for
everybody in the moment but it has been
overwhelmingly positive for 300 years
I mean look the concern here the concern
the concern this concern has played out
for for literally centuries um and you
know this is the sort of what I you know
the story of the ludd eyes
um that you may remember there was a
panic in the 2000s around uh Outsourcing
who's going to take all the jobs there
was a panic in the 2010s that robots are
going to take all the jobs
um
in 2019 before covid we had more jobs at
higher wages both in the country and in
the world than at any point human
history and so the overwhelming evidence
is that the net gain here is like just
like wildly positive and most most
people like overwhelmingly come out the
other side being huge beneficiaries of
this